hi I'm Erik Bosse in Game of Thrones
second-to-last episode made it very
clear what happens when you get in the
way of destiny the Bayeux crazy Gregor
hi burned Daenerys Targaryen destruction
of King's Landing was one of the
bloodiest most horrific sequences of the
entire series and it's really hard to
see how anything matters anymore
are we all merely children playing with
our sad wooden pig car toys waiting for
Dragon fire to consume us all I can't
live that way so I'm gonna break down
this episode with another in-depth
scene-by-scene analysis
pointing out all the subtle details that
you might have overlooked and searched
for this deeper layer of meaning that I
think we all desperately need and before
we begin big announcement new rock stars
will be hosting a live watch party of
the Game of Thrones finale episode this
Sunday May 19th in New York City
Brooklyn's hotel Red Lion check out the
description for more details and let's
get started the episode opens in
Dragonstone on an extreme closeup of a
letter that Varys is writing doesn't
require much zooming in the hinting I
guess but the pausing read it says is
not the only Targaryen left Rhaegar and
Lyanna their son lives still him by
Eddard Stark his name is is the true
heir to the Iron Throne last episode
Varys indicated that Tyrion that he was
going to take measures to weaken
Daenerys his claim to the Iron Throne in
favor of Jon Farriss also indicated
connections with other parts of Westeros
including Yara Greyjoy in the Iron
Islands and a new Prince of Dorne so
presumably Varys is sending Ravens
everywhere the Iron Islands Dorne
perhaps even the Vale The Citadel at Old
Town the iron bank of Braavos urging the
realm to back Jon instead remember Ned
Stark also used his final hours to Raven
messages around Westeros to reveal the
truth that Joffrey was not the rightful
heir creating such a divide that his
execution led to the war of the five
kings
there's his pre execution mailers might
lead to a similar conflict between
Daenerys and the other realms Varys is
visited by this girl named Martha
nothing
he won't eat we'll try again sometime
this is one of varys's little birds is
network of child spy operatives
and it sounds like varus's plan might
have been to poison Daenerys Martha in
the kitchen Dany dying this way would
make John's ascendancy a lot easier
obviously and we know Varys has plotted
to poison Dany before it could even be
possible that Varys has already been
gradually poisoning Dany steadily
contributing to her degraded physical
state and her madness various greets
John on the beach saying they say every
time the Targaryen is born the gulps
toss a coin and the world holds its
breath this is a quote that we've heard
before from Barristan Selmy and a storm
of sorts the book and from Cersei in
season two was the saying every time a
Targaryen is born the gods flip a coin
the quote describes the crapshoot of
Targaryen temperament some are noble
wise leaders others are mad and cruel
and you actually might have heard Cersei
quoting the sane in the previously on
segment before this episode ringing and
Daenerys his ears among several other
key pass lines every time a Targaryen is
born the gods flip a coin also included
in their word Olenna Tyrell advising her
to be a tracker and there's his brother
Viserys warning you don't the wake the
dragon do all of these are meant to draw
a line through all of Daenerys has past
influences to this moment her breaking
point
when she sees the only way to reclaim
her power as becoming the dragon and
striking fear in the hearts of others
landing on the side of the coin that the
realm dreads Varys then tells John men
to shy to a powder sight whether or not
they know he'd like Tyrion did last
episode Varys is reminding us again of
his riddle from season two about the
king the priest and the rich man trying
to control a cell sword power resides
where men believe it resides it's a
trick a shadow on the wall
in this example John is a cell sword
between the monarch Danny the rich man
Tyrion in the priest Varys who may
actually be an operative the Lord of
Light more on that in a sec but like the
self sword of the riddle John truly has
the power if he were to claim it the
John has given in to this trick that
others are more powerful than he is just
because they cast a larger shadow Tyrion
checks in on Danny whose hair is now
undone since season one Danny's hair has
been tied in
increasingly elaborate braids called a
Jayhawk a Dothraki word for the Warriors
braid that only gets cut if they ever
lose in battle
Danny's braid being gone now could
reflect her loss both her increasing
isolation and a loss of miss Sande who
may have been the one to tie this braid
for Danny in the past really sucks to
lose your only hairdresser Danny's
silver hair now dropping her shoulders
may sir look a lot more like her father
the Mad King Aerys the second and so
described as Sheffield gaunt look as
similar to her brother Viserys in either
case Danny has plunged further into the
bitterness and paranoia of both her mad
male relatives so various gets arrested
and brought down to the beach because
Danny warned him last season he had to
betray me I'm fine you alive heiresses
execution by fire on this Beach echoes
Stannis Baratheon's executions in the
same location in season two in the name
of the red God both Stannis and Daenerys
were unable to inspire love and their
followers forcing them to appeal to fear
in cruelty but above this Beach the
night sky glitters with interesting red
stars good Varys his death here also be
under the eyes of the red God the Lord
of Light last season on the cliffs
overlooking this Beach red priestess
lady Melisandre told Varys I have to die
in this strange country just like you
there is this whole life has been tied
to the red God as a boy a sorcerer
castrated him and threw his parts into a
fire the flames turned blue and I heard
a voice answer his call in season six
chief red priestess kinvaras shook
theorists by somehow knowing about this
moment should I tell you what the voice
said should I tell you the name of the
one who spoke and note that there's
removed his rings before getting
arrested and a close-up showed flames
reflecting in his eyes both also true
for lady Melisandre back in episode
three this season her eyes glowed with
flames for the power of the red God and
right before her death she removed her
necklace also just like the army of the
Dead looming in from a wall of darkness
here drogon appears from the dark a
night that is dark and full of terrors
so if Varys is playing a role for the
Lord of Light what is that role
Varys is a bigger game changer than it
seems not only did he spread the flame
of the truth of John
identity around Westeros Varys was
always the last line of defense for the
realm innocent children so in a broader
sense Varys is removal exposes the
realms children to the horrors of war
you see how that happens this episode
John witnesses this execution there's
definitely some judgment in his eyes
John comes from the northern tradition
of just executions where to quote Eddard
Stark the one who passes the sentence
should swing the sword
John carried out that kind of justice on
Jonas Lent and his traitorous brothers
of the Nights Watch but Danny's
execution of various reminds him what
Sam warned him about Danny
executed Randall and dick on now he's
seeing this brash temperament firsthand
and before move on little detail here
tyrion affectionately touches varus's
arm and various reacts in shock that's
because Varys has rarely if ever been
physically touched by any other
character on this show he's always been
presented as this kind of ghostly
intangible spider master of whispers but
in this moment this touch reminds us
that he is human and sadly mortal you
know more sadly very flammable Danny
gives gray warmest Sunday's slave collar
or one position assigned it kept it
because it represented how Danny was the
breaker of chains but now by burning it
grey worm and Danny are burning the
bridge - Danny's past goal to liberate
with limited bloodshed as she did to the
slaves of young Chi and marine and
shortly after this she tells John that
in Westeros she'll never be as loved as
he is so when Danny and John kissed she
puts her hands around his neck actually
later in this episode Jamie and surcease
final moment Jamie embraces her the same
way and in a sign of more brotherly love
the mountain also chokes the Hound could
this mean that John and Danny will
suffer the same mutually assured
destruction that those other two
pairings did tyrion proposed this plan
to have the bells of King's Landing rung
when the city surrenders to call off the
assault but notice that Danny doesn't
consent to it she just kind of gives a
slight nod to grey worm wait for me
outside the city you'll know when it's
time this hints that for Danny and grey
worm sack in King's Landing isn't just
about strategy it's about sloppy revenge
and later it'll be great worm who
initiates that shift into operations
scorched earth spearing the surrendered
Lannister captain after seeing Danny and
drogon trichiasis City Danny's dark turn
is signaled by the music here composed
of Ramin Djawadi was on fire this
episode as
so much of the episode was in here he
plays the dragon the wolf theme but
instead of these standard violins used
the low low notes of an upright bass it
creates this ominous sense of dread in
King's Landing director Miguel Zapata
make focuses on this short-haired woman
and her daughter
now these anonymous civilians are
exactly the innocence that Varys was
seeking to protect and support Neck
returns to them over and over throughout
the episode as kind of point-of-view
characters to depict this ground-level
fall out Tyrion finds his brother Jaime
in captivity telling him to find a boat
that sir Davos will have left for him in
the same shoreside tunnel location at
least the red cape that they use last
season he begs Jaime to go with Cersei
to live quietly in Pentos leaning to
Pentos would be exactly what Dany and
Viserys did when Circe's husband Robert
took the throne from them but in the
brothers final singing together Tyrion
frees Jamie coming full circle with
Jaime freeing Tyrion at the end of
season 4 we'll have to see what
consequences this has for Tyrion Danny
did tell him last episode the next time
you fail me will be your last but moving
on to King's Landing
jadi scores the moments leading up to
the battle with some interesting
orchestration
he's playing three notes from an upright
bass bending each one down it's actually
a variation on his bass line from the
jerk Aris theme which we first heard
when Daenerys and Drogo intercourse
Oliver asked the poor's but there those
notes Bend upwards so inverting the
notes to bend downward here reflects
Danny's inversion of her priorities when
FreeNAS the boards and airs burnt the
city but spared the common people in
slaves now Daenerys does not at all make
that distinction but supportive scammer
certainly does in this pre-battle
montage the director mixes shots of
preparing soldiers with the common folk
a boy playing with the toy women
shuttering their windows a baby crying
and again this unnamed mother and
daughter whom if you notice the hound
and Arya shove pass to get into the red
keep right before the gates closed arya
notices them before the to get locked
out it's about nick is using these
commoners as foils to arya here arya
selfishly takes these twos place in line
and dooms them later after stepping back
from the fight Arya becomes a first
responder struggling to help these same
people you're on Greyjoy's the first to
spot drogon whom you can barely make out
outlined in the sun the very first time
you're on look skyward this partly
explains how Daenerys was able to get
the jump on the iron fleet despite being
caught with her pants down last episode
Daenerys is flying with the Sun at her
back she's using the glare the Sun to
blind her on and to get a head start on
the dive actually in Lord the Rings the
two towers Gandalf
similarly uses sunlight in this charge
with the rope Hyrum at Helm's Deep Dany
is also smart to stay low along the
water for seeing the scorpions to slowly
regain so that she can torch them before
they get their shots off some have also
speculated that drogon might have been
more effective against the artillery
than like raiga Laura's Ariane work
because he has Danny on his back like a
second set of eyes to help him duck and
roll meanwhile at the north gate the
golden company lines up against John's
allied forces the golden company's sigil
is a pile of skulls with a Pike through
them
the skulls representing the past
captain's general the current captain is
Harry Strickland who does not sound like
Game of Thrones character he sounds like
the guy your dad golf's with his whole
purpose this season seems to be to put a
semi recognize the wolf face on the
other side of this battle line because
Sebastian a deliberate
frames strickland the same way he framed
John in the Battle of the bastards in
season six one camera crane up shot and
a later shot of Strickland facing the
cavalry charge but unlike John
Strickland retreats and fear but the
focus on his perspective is a tactic by
sapota neck to blur the lines between
the heroes and the villains of this
battle and throughout the sequence we
will see how it increasingly devolves
into a messy slaughter in which there is
no clear good side drogon torches the
defenses and the Allied forces breach
the city and as Cersei observes this
Joey scores the dragon fire with a
Targaryen theme but played in a minor
key so even though this feels like a
victory that we should celebrate the
music for shadows how Daenerys his
bloodlust will plunge this victory into
pure horror this dissent is scored with
a shift in the music to this familiar
tune
[Music]
you might recognize this as gelotti's
light of the seven music it's the theme
from the season six finale when Cersei
watched the Sept of Baelor burn and
wildfire so using the score again here
is linking these moments of terrorism
mad Queens seizing the Iron Throne with
fear in fire the Lannister soldiers
surrender in the city bells ring which
Tyrion intends is a white flag of course
signaling the ending of further
bloodshed this episode is titled the
bells and belts carry an interesting
significance on the series remember in
season two prior to the last time King's
Landing was under attack Varys Hall
Tyrion I've always hated the bells they
ring fahara
the dead King a city under siege wedding
exactly
indeed bells have often been the sound
of coming doom on Game of Thrones they
rang at Baylor for Ned Stark's execution
they rang the morning of the Sept of
Baelor destruction and when Daenerys had
her dragons stolen from her in Qarth in
season two the city bells rang then -
[Music]
and now just as Varys predicted these
bells ring for horror once more Daenerys
eyes the red keep a castle built by her
Targaryen ancestors in the castle stolen
from her family forcing her into exile
in a long brutal journey home and unlike
the others of her forces down on the
street Daenerys is alone atop drogon
evoking another past quote from the
previously on montage from Maester Aemon
Daenerys his distant relative garyun
alone in the terrible she remember that
line ended with a foreshadowing
appearance of John secretly another
Targaryen alone in the world and now
Daenerys is isolationist convinced her
that fear is the only way to win respect
to the people so a military surrender is
not enough she feels that she needs to
decimate as much as a city as possible
root in stem there's actually a
fascinating visual detail that you might
have missed here but first thank you to
manscaped for sponsoring this video
look fellas doing any grooming
downstairs can make a guy feel like the
knight King around Valyrian steel you
know just one Nick and
plus it turns out that you should not
use the same razor to trim your beard
that you use to trim other places
something I definitely knew already
manscaped calm is the only men's brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene with tools created by a team
of aerospace engineers who were actually
featured on Shark Tank so this is the
lawnmower 2.0 it's a waterproof trimmer
with a powerful 6,000 rpm motor and as a
replaceable ceramic blade head with skin
safe technology meaning you won't get
nicked or snagged her rooting stems like
varus manscape comelet's to get a
replacement blade delivered every three
months to ensure the trimmer stays
hygienic and guys their perfect package
2.0 manscaping kit also comes with crop
preserver moisturizing deodorant crop
revive or spray crop cleanser shower gel
they got Cologne and my favorite this
magic matte disposable shaving mat with
comics to read in there so you can stop
flying in your Game of Thrones books you
know nothing's more embarrassing and
landing on a dance of dragons and
finding your random body hairs
bookmarking certain pages so give
manscaped a shot it's risk free with a
30 day money-back guarantee and here's a
special free gift for all of our new
Rockstar subscribers leash and a travel
bag yeah baby get 20% off plus free
shipping plus this free gift with the
code rock stars 20 at manscaped comm ok
back to King's Landing as drogon soars
over the city there's this shot of a
shadow over the roofs which is an image
from brand's future vision back in
season 6
this means that brand actually foresaw
the destruction of King's Landing by
dragon fire but he has also said the
future only comes to him in fragments so
he's a good chance that bran didn't yet
fully understand what would happen or
why people keep trying to hang tire
swings from him Daenerys is charged
triggers a moral free-for-all on the
streets below grey worm Spears who
surrendered Lannister captain actually
the script for this episode described
grey worm as an angel of death
setting up the religious imagery at the
end of the episode and as the Allied
forces are depicted as the enemies the
posh Mecca includes other shots painting
Lannister soldiers as heroes with Jon
seen one of them waving civilians to
safety looking like a fire fighter this
reversal continues as Jon has to kill
one of his own soldiers to stop him from
raping a woman this horror of war was
actually foreshadowed by a very dark
description of the previous sack of
King's Landing by Roberts forces this is
in a scene with Sir Jorah Barristan
Selmy and Daenerys I was in Kingsland
after the SEC HEVC you know what I saw
Oh children babies children old men more
women break them you can count there's a
beast in every man and it stirs when you
put a sword in his hand george RR martin
has always emphasized this kind of
gritty realism in his depictions of war
actually critiquing JRR tolkien in the
Lord of the Rings books despite his
obvious love and adoration of that
series he quibbled with Tolkien for
depicting war as a battle of good versus
evil the fate of civilization but Martin
has argued that the vast majority of
wars throughout history are not like
that they're actually a lot more like
the battle that we saw in this episode
so while this battle goes on Jamie runs
into euron greyjoy the two rivals for
Circe's hard to have this vicious battle
Jaime ends up defeating him but not
after taking a few fatal stabs to one
side but I would say it's fitting for
euron greyjoy the pirate king to die
this way after resurrecting from the
water to bring him full circle with his
drowned god baptism what is dead may
never die drogue on targets the red
Keith blasting up the Lannister sigil in
the window above the Iron Throne and we
already assured the status of the Iron
Throne itself but the red cape is now
looking a lot like Daenerys his vision
of the ruined red cape and the house of
the undying in season 2 but we thought
was snow may actually be falling ash do
you remember the opening credit imagery
throughout the season is depicted King's
Landing as clockwork cogs in a wheel so
by destroying it Daenerys is kind of
making good on her promise to break the
wheel and nice touch here a piece of
rubble shatters Circe's wineglass the
most heartbreaking thing for her to see
probably hybrid tells her to retreat to
make oars both pass that's the red key
bunker where she and Sansa waited out
the battle bike water Magus room fast
would be a better place to wait out the
storm and we hear the sad music
[Music]
this music is the rains of castamere
normally the Lannister victory song but
played here ironically if you think
about the lyrics the song is about
Circe's ancestor Tytos Lannister who
decimated the rival house rain rain rain
being a double entendre in the song they
burned their home castamere and executed
every man woman and child of their house
that decimation has now come around to
House Lannister as Cersei gets ousted by
a mad queen who's even more villainous
than she is no one wonders what songs
were right about Daenerys Wow the mother
of dragons burned everyone for no reason
and that's see and the song because
we're dead as they leave the dragon fire
consumes the city along with these green
wildfire plumes some are speculative
these could have been traps laid out by
Cersei as land mines for the invaders or
maybe false flag sister she's set up in
case Daenerys chose not to used rogue on
Cersei could still burn parts of the
city and blame it on Danny I'd remember
Jaime told Brienne in the bath and
season 3 that the Mad King ordered his
pyromancers to place caches of wildfire
all over the city so these explosions
may have been those caches finally
detonating so if you think about it
Daenerys is finishing her mad father's
work with madness of her own in the red
cape map room the Hound restrains Arya
from going to kill Cersei and he grabs
her while they're standing on the
Riverlands of the map a nod to Sandor
taken Arya captive in the Riverlands in
season 3 but also protecting her The
Hound convinces Arya to turn away from a
revenge quest since Circe's as good as
dead anyway
and Arya says goodbye send oh thank you
this is the first and only time arya
calls the Hound by his first name
paralleling the moment Jaime and Brienne
dropped Jaime's Kingslayer moniker hound
then confronts his brother Gregor the
mountain giving fans that Clegane bow
we've been waiting for the mountain
kills Qyburn smashing him against the
wall Oh like he does that comment on
season six and Ike before the events of
the series the baby of Elia Martell
Qyburn has always been a dr.
Frankenstein figure to the mountain so
it's fitting that Frankenstein is killed
by his monster here sabasha makes tatius
fight on these stairs which crumble when
the upper levels of the tower collapse
so this is literally a stairway to
nowhere reflecting the fight between the
Clegane brothers as aimless without
destination or prize just an epic cage
match between two titans the mountain
loses his helmet revealing this bald
pale scarred face of strong man half
Thor bjornsen
similar to the reveal of Darth Vader's
guard face under his black armor Gregor
also strips off his chest plate because
he doesn't care if he gets stabbed it
brings Gregor full circle with how we
first saw goranson as the character
shirtless huge and pummeling his
opponent he grabs a hound by the head
and presses into his eyes merely
question his head just like he did at
the viper in season 4 but before he can
break all of our hearts the Hound stabs
him in the eye just like Lyanna Mormont
did to the Giant in episode 3 and the
Hound dive tackles his brother through
the wall into the fire
similar to Frodo tackling Gollum and the
ring in the fire Mount Doom so the Hound
dies by finally confronting his fear of
fire and letting it consume both himself
and his greatest enemy the brother who
gave him these burn scars Cersei and
Jaime reunite in the map room the last
place they saw each other at the end of
last season and as the building crumbles
a crack forms across the map floor of
Westeros separating the southern half of
Westeros from the Riverlands of the
northern half this could be
foreshadowing the new dividing line
that's forming between Daenerys in the
south and the other realms like Sansa in
the north
Arya wanders the chaotic streets outside
and a long unbroken tracking shot it's
hard to watch there's death and carnage
everywhere she gets trampled and helped
to her feet by these same short haired
mother after more collapsing buildings
and rubble she later wakes up with a
nasty head wound all this chaos here was
actually designed to evoke the infamous
firebombing of Dresden in World War 2
which much like Dany firebombing King's
Landing was an air raid on what the
Allies considered to be an enemy city
but the bombings famously led to high
civilian casualties and have been
critiqued by many historians as
unnecessary but Daenerys this behavior
here is clearly nothing short of war
crimes her dragon represents the power
of nuclear weapons in our world the
ability to level an entire city it's
very much an unfair advantage actually
the mother and daughter who saved Arya
are found as charred corpses evoke in
the way human remains were found in the
aftermath of her Oshima and Nagasaki and
the volcanic eruption of pompeii many
are saying the imagery here also evokes
the 9/11 terrorist attacks with arya
caked and dust and ash and blood piles
of rubble collapsing buildings ash
wafting through the air and burn victims
jumping from buildings really no matter
what historical lens you'd look at this
sapota net1 and our empathy to be solely
with the victims of this city he'll
notice Daenerys doesn't utter a single
word for the entire sequence and
actually the tower that nearly collapses
on our
is the belltower that Daenerys earlier
ignored you can actually hear the ring
of that bell when it crashes to the
ground by aria
so Daenerys bypassing the bells isn't
just a metaphorical fu her destruction
literally weaponized as one of these
bells against her allies also I couldn't
find it but somewhere among the streets
of King's Landing Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers makes a cameo that he
plays a commoner helping a woman that
makes a run for it down in the dungeons
Cersei and Jaime find their path blocked
and as Cersei accepts her fate the light
of the seven piano notes return briefly
but as Jamie tells her nothing else
matters only us the music transforms
back into the rains of castamere
[Music]
so haunted by her decision to play with
fire this Lannister Queen now pays the
price for angering an even more fiery
queen the descendant of the dragon
skulls that now close in on her Jaime
Lannister meanwhile dies the way he told
Bronn he always wanted to die in season
five how do you want to go you know now
I agree it was really frustrating to see
Jamie Lee Brienne behind and join his
toxic sister and death here but despite
Jamie's redeeming moves over the years I
guess Jamie remains addicted to Cersei
and like any addict the risk of relapse
is high Jaime ends this series is a
cautionary tale like Smeagol of Lord of
the Rings another sometimes redemptive
addict who ends up ended it all clinging
to his precious but I agree it's a
bummer and this brings us back to Arya
shell shocked by her apocalyptic
surroundings looking like the last
person on earth Jawad he scores his
chaos with screeching strings which as
arya collects herself the notes limp
their way into the house stark theme
[Music]
Aria finds the mother and daughter from
before but now they're dead from dragon
fire the girl's hand still clutches her
toy a white horse well it used to be
white before drogon ruined it and then
as if by magic or some divine spiritual
force the white horse appears some are
saying this actually looks like captain
Strickland's horse from earlier in the
episode I'm sure about that but this
horse brings up some key symbolism in
the book of Revelation there are the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse the
white horse conquest or victory the red
horse war the black horse famine in The
Pale Horse death many interpret Arya
riding the horse to be the pale horse
for ashen horse in some translations I
looked and behold an ashen and he who
sat on it had the name of death Arya is
an embodiment of death carrying the
power of the many-faced God but we
should point out that this horse is
actually white and he's covered in red
blood and the girls toy horse is black
so really all four horsemen are present
in this scene some are speculating that
this horse could be brand Morgan into a
horse to help Arya but I'd be pretty
surprised if this horse of all animals
is the animal that brand finally decides
to warg into and I you know dragons but
the final image of Arya presents a mix
of hope and despair arya appears to be
fleeing the conflict taking the hounds
advice to release herself from vengeance
but let's remember Arya has passed to
the many-faced God and the ashes of
King's Landing to echo some important
history in Westeros see past ancient
Valyria was also destroyed in a similar
way by some mysterious event the
Targaryen xand their dragons were the
only survivors of the doom of Valyria
but it was rumored that the faceless men
actually played a role in that disaster
the faceless men wanted to rid the world
of the evils of dragon fire so similarly
Arya may now play a role in saving the
next generation from this kind of fire
because all the names on our kill list
are now dead which makes room for one
more name on that list again this
episode is titled the bells the bells of
surrender that Daenerys ignored and the
bells that have historically announced a
change in power or as past generations
have considered it the flipping of a
coin with what kind of ruler this next
Targaryen would be the bells of the
title also remind us of the famous quote
from poet John Donne ask Not For Whom
the Bell Tolls it tolls for thee his
idea was that no man is an island and a
loss of any life is a loss for all so
hear the bells don't just toll for the
loss of Circe's rule they told for the
loss of every life of every victim of
this bad
whatever you felt after gameofthrones
penultimate episode it is a stark
reminder of the theme that runs
throughout George RR Martin's works that
the horror of war transforms all of us
into beasts or prey regardless of what
colors we wear do you now see Daenerys
as the cruelest villain of Game of
Thrones how does she compared to other
cruel villains like Cersei Ramsay Bolton
the knight king comment down below with
your thoughts and follow me on instagram
and twitter at da boss and another
reminder to join us in person for our
Game of Thrones finale watch party at
the hotel Red Lion and Brooklyn this
Sunday May 19th we will watch the finale
together and host a live taping of our
after show lots of fun stuff is plan so
check out the link in the description
below for tickets and more details thank
you for joining me and if you live next
door to the mother of dragons maybe a
take down your wind chimes
[Music]